[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous alors moi aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler de guerre des sexes
mais bien que je me sente impliqué dans
le débat actuel sur l'égalité des droits
aux femmes ce n'est pas ce sujet qui
fera l'objet des montagnes tôt que ce
soir je vous parlais d'un combat entre
le spermatozoïde et l'ovule site
c'est à dire entre les gènes du père et
de la mère
bon pour l'instant ça doit vous paraître
complètement pas concret donc avant de
rentrer dans les détails mais c'est moi
commencer par le début je vais vous
poser une question
dites moi qu'est ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit quand je vous dis le terme
reproduction animale
alors pour avoir un avis de la
population générale
j'ai demandé à notre bon vieil ami
google et voilà c'est ce qui m'a répondu
alors c'est peut-être que vous aviez en
tête mois pour être honnête c'est à peu
près ce que j'avais en tête
cependant on oublie que la majorité des
animaux n'ont pas besoin de partenaires
sexuels pour se reproduire
en effet beaucoup d'insectes certains
arthropodes et même des reptiles peuvent
se reproduire sans partenaire sexuel on
appelle cela de la parthénogenèse alors
comment ça fonctionne appartenant genèse
c'est le fait qu'une femelle peut
activer elle-même son nouveau site par
division cellulaire et ensuite donner
vie à un nouvel individu mais les
mammifères sont incapables de faire de
la parthénogenèse alors pourquoi
pourquoi ils salamandre peut faire de la
parthénogenèse et nous par exemple les
humains nous ne sommes pas capables qui
nous qu'est ce que nous avons en moins
ou alors en plus qui nous nous ne le
perds mon père mais pas cette question
c'est une question de biologie
fondamentale que des chercheurs se sont
posés dans les années 1980 c'est partie
de deux groupes de chercheurs l'un aux
états unis à philadelphie et l'autre en
angleterre et en fait il voulait
comprendre ce que ils ont mis des
expériences pour comprendre ce que les
mammifères sont capables de faire de
l'appartenance younès
pour cela ils ont utilisé des noyaux de
cellules reproductrices les noyaux parce
que c'est là que ce qui est contenu
notre adn c'est à dire le matériel
génétique qui va permettre de donner vie
à la nouvelle génération
alors ils ont effectué des expériences
sur la souris qu'un organisme modèle
pour étudier des questions biologiques
chez les mammifères
ils ont mis en place trois types
d'expériences la première ils ont pris
un noyau d'un spermatozoïde un noyau
d'un nouveau site
ils ont fusionné pour donner un oeuf
fertiliser et ils ont observé qu'un
embryon se développer et donner vie
ensuite à une souris adultes en bonne
santé
c'est en fait de la fécondation in vitro
deuxième type d'expérience cette fois ci
ils prennent le noyau de deux noyaux
venant de deux nouveaux sites
partant du fait qu'on a besoin de deux
mâts de copies du matériel génétique
pour donner un être vivant
cependant à ce moment-là l'embryon ne
peut pas se développer ce qui se passe
en fait c'est que l'embryon lui-même se
développent et grossi mais les tissus
extra embryonnaires c'est à dire le
futur plaçant pas ce qui permet de
nourrir l'embryon pendant la grossesse
eux ne se développe pas ok dernière
expérience
cette fois ci ils prennent le noyau de
deux spermatozoïdes
il est fusionnent et ils observent la
même chose pas développement d'embryons
ce qui était différent c'est que là
c'était l'embryon lui-même qui ne
pouvaient pas se développer alors que
les tissus embryonnaires se développer
normalement
alors qu'est ce que nous disent des
expériences premièrement ça nous montre
que chez les mammifères nous avons
besoin d'un jeune homme paternel et dans
une eau maternelle pour donner un
embryon viable mais ça nous dit aussi
que la contribution de chacun des
parents n'est pas la même il y a
apparemment une influence parental pour
donner un embryon alors je vais vous
donner deux exemples pour illustrer
cette influence parental le premier
c'est l'exemple des espèces hybrides
j'ai pas si vous le savez mais des lions
et des tigres sont capables de
s'accoupler et de donner naissance à des
espèces viable mais seulement selon la
transmission parental on aura 2
est-ce différente si une femelle tigre
s'accouple avec un maillot on va avoir
ce qu'on appelle un ligue au caire est
un gros animal pesant presque 400 kg
c'est à dire à peu près deux fois le
poids de chacun de ses parents vous
l'avez en image à gauche mais al'inverse
si une lionne s'accouple avec un mâle
tigres on a un petit gros le tigre on
est un plus ou un gros animal mais cette
fois-ci 150 kg et comme vous pouvez le
voir sur l'image
ils sont visiblement différent ce qui
peut paraître étrange puisqu'ils ont
chacun le même matériel génétique une
dose d'un tigre une dose d'un lion la
seule chose qui change c'est la
transmission parental deuxième exemple
qui cette fois ci s'intéresse aux
humains c'est le cas de deux syndrome de
maladies neuro développemental donc ces
deux maladies mais ils s'appellent les
syndrome d'angelman les syndrome de
prader willi sont dues à la même
mutation
c'est à dire aux mêmes défauts
génétiques mais si c'est la mère qui
transmet la mutation l'enfant aura le
syndrome d'angelman où les enfants vont
avoir des difficultés vont avoir ce des
retards développementaux ils vont être
très petit ils vont avoir aussi des
retards mentaux
alors qu'au contraire si c'est le père
qui transmet cette même mutation
les enfants auront le syndrome de prader
willi ou ses enfants vont développer des
problèmes de satiété ils vont manger
beaucoup et développer ensuite des obus
de l'obésité et d'autres problèmes
métaboliques une fois plus vous voyez
ici que ces deux maladies sont dues à la
même mutation ou même défaut génétique
mais selon la transmission parental on
n'aura pas du tout et même syndrome
etonnant non
moi je trouve ça surprenant et même
fascinant alors je ne suis pas présenté
je m'appelle ville yenga laser j'ai 26
ans et je suis en dernière année de
doctorat à l'institut curie et cette
histoire d' influence parentale ce que
je viens de vous raconter là moi ça me
fascine si voulu comprendre comment ça
fonctionne
pourquoi on a ça comment ça se fait
comment ça a évolué au cours des
générations alors pour la petite
histoire comment j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser à ça alors quand on nous
apprend des concepts de la génétique
quelque chose que peut-être vous savez
déjà
on nous dit que chacun de nos gènes sont
là en deux copies une copie venant de
notre père une copie venant de notre
mère très bien on enregistre ça c'est
assez simple jusque là mais quand on
avance un peu plus dans des études de
biologie
il ya un moment où on nous dit qu'en
fait tout ça c'est des mensonges à ce
que certains gènes a beaucoup fait
environ 150 sur les 25000 on a au total
certains gènes sont là en une seule dose
à deux mais une seule une seule dos
parce que certains sont actifs seulement
30 quand ils sont transmis par notre
maire et certains seulement quand ils
sont transmis par notre père
moi ça ça m'intrigue comment ça se fait
ce que finalement c'est le même matériel
le même matériel génétique mais est
quelque chose qui fait que selon cissé
pas part aux mamans qui nous le transmet
sa sera pas actif de la même façon alors
la réponse est c'est épigénétiques ce
fameux termes savants que vous devez
entendre dans les médias parfois qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
alors l'épigénétique comme son
étymologie le dit c'est quelque chose
qui vient au dessus de la génétique une
information supplémentaire qui va
permettre de décoder nos gènes entre
guillemets et dans ce cas de ces gènes
qui s'exprime en une seule dose
l'épigénétique est une empreinte
parental que ce soit la mère ou le père
qui nous donne ce gène
on n'aura pas la même empreinte
génétique le même message épigénétiques
bon parent est encore un peu
alors pour expliquer un peu plus les
piscines éthiques
apparemment il ya pas mal de musiciens
dans la salle alors prenons l'exemple
d'une partition de musique un chef
d'orchestre qui va donner une
information à ses musiciens
s'il a juste le texte sur sa partition
il pourra pas envoyé de signal
il pourra pas donné d'instructions à ses
musiciens mais si l' on ajoute les notes
de musique est bien là ça y est il peut
lire la partition donner les
instructions aux musiciens et la musique
arrive pas au final l'épigénétique c'est
un peu comme ça c'est qu'on a notre adn
ces fameux à tcg nos gènes mais on peux
pas les lire on peut en faire
on peut pas comprendre ce qu'ils veulent
dire sans l'épigénétique l'épigénétique
ça va être des molécules qui viennent se
fixer dessus pour ne dire pas en fait
ce gène il veut dire ça à tel moment à
un peu plus tard il veut dire ça ok mais
alors ça fait quoi exactement
l'épigénétique on en parle beaucoup
parce que il ya une influence au niveau
de l'environnement
ce qu'on mange ce qu'on l'on respire
alors un exemple que j'aime bien c'est
l'exemple de la reine
comment devient ton alors vous allez me
dire ce qu'elle est en train de raconter
on devient reine d'angleterre à cause de
l'épigénétique rassurez-vous pas du tout
par contre c'est des abeilles c'est le
cas les larves d'abeilles
il va y en avoir une dans la colonie une
seule qui va manger de la gelée royale
est celle là eh ben il deviendra reine
alors que les autres elles sont ouvrière
toute leur vie alors ce qui se passe
c'est que dans la gelée royale
il ya des molécules chimiques qui vont
venir modifier ces gènes créer des
modifications épigénétiques qui vont
faire qu'elle va devenir reine la reine
vit beaucoup plus longtemps que les
autres elle vit de 3 à 4 ans l arène
surtout elle peut se reproduire elle est
fertile toutes les autres qui n'ont pas
mangé de la gelée royale
elles seront ouvrière vivront que
quelques mois et n'auront pas de
neutrons pour pas se reproduire
ok super les abeilles mais alors nous
les yeux ce que je mange de la gelée
royale et je deviens reine d'angleterre
non par contre on sait que ce que
on a des expériences qui nous ont montré
récemment en tout cas que selon ce que
l'on mange selon notre régime
alimentaire plus ou moins gras plus ou
moins riches en protéines ont-elles un
tel produit chimique
ça peut modifier notre un pigeonneau en
tout cas il ya des expériences et des
publications scientifiques qu'on montre
et cela cela sourit au fédéral et on
sait on a identifié certaines molécules
dans certains aliments qu'ils étaient
capables de modifier notre effigie nos
cela peut être intéressant car ça peut
modifier notre épine génome et surtout
être transmis aux générations futures et
ensuite avoir des maladies liés au
métabolisme
ça reste à l'état de publication
préliminaire bien sûr au niveau des
toxines et des polluants aussi je sais
pas si vous avez entendu parler
peut-être des perturbateurs endocriniens
on sait que certains perturbateurs
endocriniens peuvent modifier notre
épigénétiques est donc l'expression de
certains de nos gènes et que cela peut
avoir des conséquences sur notre santé
au niveau du stress et du comportement
certaines publications ont montré que
les piges et que cela pouvait changer
notre épigénétique
pour cela je voudrais un peu appuyé sur
la [ __ ] de frein parce que c'est des
données qui sont pas encore purement
statistique et qui peuvent pas être
concluante sur la santé au niveau 2 des
humains ok donc l'épigénétique c'est
dans notre environnement
ça peut modifier nos gènes et ça peut
être néfaste mais l'épigénétique ce
n'est pas seulement néfaste comme je
voulais dit avec l'exemple de la musique
on en a besoin on a besoin de ces
modifications pour lire nos gènes par
exemple dans toutes les cellules
on a le même adn mais si une cellule de
la peau devient une cellules de la peau
une cellules du foie ou cellules du foie
c'est parce que certaines modifions et
modifications épigénétiques en ont dicté
à ces cellules d'exprimer un certain
gène ou non alors je sais pas peut-être
que là en ce moment vous êtes en train
de vous dire c'est super ce qu'elle nous
raconte mais au début j'ai commencé mon
tout en vous parlant de guerre des sexes
quel est le rapport avec tout ça
alors pour ça je vais revenir sur les
ces jeunes qui s'expriment en une seule
dose une fascine tant en fait on a
besoin de comprendre comment ces gènes
ont évolué avec le temps
pourquoi ils sont conservés en une seule
dose sachant que s'ils ont eu de ces
gènes sont s'ils ont un défaut on aura
0,2 et ceux ci peut être défectueux donc
pourquoi ils sont conservés alors ce
qu'on a observé dans la fonction de ces
gènes c'est que ceux qui sont transmis
par la maman sont des jeunes qui ont
tendance à réguler négativement la
croissance de l'embryon et du futur
êtres vivants au contraire ceux qui sont
transmis par le papa ont tendance à
réguler positivement la croissance de
l'embryon dire qui aurait comme un
combat au niveau de ces gènes pour
réguler la croissance de l'embryon à
partir de cette observation une théorie
a été mise en place
théorique est appelée théorie du conflit
d'intérêts reproductif un conflit entre
la mère et le père pour réguler la
ressource de l'embryon en effet la mer
qui portent l'embryon aurait tendance à
vouloir garder et nutriments pour elle
même et aussi pour les futures
générations à venir
donc elle voudrait elle aurait tendance
à vouloir limiter la croissance de
l'embryon au contraire le père veut que
sa descendance au la plus vigoureuse
possible la plus forte possible pour
transmettre le mieux possible ces gènes
et il aurait tendance à vouloir que
l'embryon soit le plus gros possible
c'est bien sûr une théorie évolutif qui
n'a pas de sens biologique qui sert
juste à expliquer l'évolution de
certains gènes en regardant leurs
fonctions mais moi je m'intéresse
particulièrement cette théorie parce que
je travaille moi même sur l'un de ces
gènes qui est transmis par le père et
j'ai pu montrer qu'il joue un rôle
positif sur la croissance alors cette
théorie elle s'appelle conflits
d'intérêts reproductif pour moi il n'y a
pas de conflit
on parle juste d'un intérêt et
reproductifs qui en fait entre celui de
la mère et du père est le même c'est à
dire que l'embryon
se développe bien et qu'on ait une
descendance qui transmettent ces jeunes
de mieux possible
alors pour revenir sur ce terme de
guerre des sexes
je voudrais citer une phrase que j'aime
bien dans ricky singer qui dit qu'en
fait personne ne gagnera jamais la
guerre des sexes parce qu'il ya trop de
fraternisation avec l'ennemi pour finir
en tant que femme scientifique milieu
dans lequel les femmes sont encore trop
peu représenté quand on arrive à des
hauts postes hiérarchiques vous ai
montré aujourd'hui que dans un embryon
on a besoin pour qu'il se développe
normalement du monde tribution paternel
et maternel est bien en sciences comme
dans toute autre discipline on a besoin
d'une contribution homme femme égale et
je vous ai mis aussi ici une photo de
mon équipe de recherche
ce que la recherche dans un laboratoire
ça se fait en équipe en communiquant
énormément et on a la chance d'avoir une
contribution égale hommes-femmes et je
ne sais pas c'est peut-être qu'il fait
ça qui fait que cette équipe soit aussi
formidable aussi motivantes au quotidien
merci beaucoup de votre attention
[Applaudissements]